[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jean luc mais aussi d'être à nos
côtés mais à quoi sert il
cyril féraud amir message un macabre
voilà l'animateur marieur je vais jamais
me lâcher en fait non jamais non je
pense que la vie était foutue ces avis
maintenant est ce que voulait une
question bien sûr on aime ça alors
allons-y jour je m'appelle annette à
part cyril je trouve que vous êtes
globalement une belle bande de tocards
donc je voulais savoir comment faites
vous pour recevoir autant d'invités
prestigieux
[Applaudissements]
moi j'en ai tous des tocards même moi
mais c'est vrai que ma modeste vous
pensez vraiment que nous avons un atout
car oui vaut franchement à part au ping
pong part mais je comprends ces
questions à l'aide mais en fait vous
avez répondu vous même les gens ne
viennent pas pour les chroniqueurs mais
pour cyril qui est leur ami
car si elle a une particularité il est
ami proche de tout le monde
comme la semaine dernière doc gynéco
temps mais je connais hyper bien pas je
sais vous l'aviez pas vu depuis dix ans
mais mais vous le connaissez super bien
et il l'a dit à l'antenne donc doc
gynéco qui nous a surpris car il a une
particularité incroyable quand il prend
de l'hélium
sa voix ne change pas c'est le seul au
monde
du moins c'est ce que je croyais mais
j'ai mené mon enquête
[Applaudissements]
il me dois de l'argent et n'a jamais été
sur tf1 et ses sourires et pour mon
chevet
[Applaudissements]
il n'a jamais été sur tf1 non vous savez
que si vous respirez l'air d'un ballon
gonflé par doc gynéco one off par contre
vous conseille de ne pas prendre le
volant juste après alors parce qu'il
était bien invité en forme et enfin
celle qui a passé le meilleur moment je
pense que c'est marouane woods qui était
à côté de lui et non dès le premier
échange elle a compris qu'elle allait
passer un grand moment
elle est vraiment il ya des moments
mythiques notamment quand doc va
demander à mme marois de quel quartier
il vient et qu'elle va lui répondre
strasbourg normalement avec cette
réponse personne n'aurait pu enchaîner
lui ça passe facile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autour d'elle pour toi ma chérie viens
voir le docteur
[Musique]
sera heureux quand même d'offrir à harry
et mégane un échantillon de ça clame
rigolos ou grosse boulette
[Applaudissements]
je voulais j'étais petit c'était le toc
[Musique]
ça m'a fait rire ses chaussures dans le
vert c'est intéressant tout ça
à savoir il ya douze ans le chanteur
country jambes pour jouer
d'un côté les deux seuls propriété de
change michael estimées à près de 10
millions d'euros
aussi les objets personnels de l'âge de
10 ans
démis tout droit et les coutumes et des
parfums c'est toi c'est arrivé aux
jeunes
kobe sacré au bo liés au jour dernier
est l avis chasse canadiens encore à
paris de la pièce adieu cardinaux est
accusé des crimes effroyables celle de
dieu
ce qui se serait débrouillé
évident alors qu'elle était une femme
est traînée par les cheveux
elle dit avoir été violée et mieux
compris je suis tellement fan de toi
exceptionnelle il est tellement drôle de
laurel suel ceux des mois je l'adoré
mais moi aussi je suis fan du gars sont
vraiment formidables mais j'aimerais
tellement être aussi cool curie
notamment au niveau de la diction
mabillon sans qu'il ait jamais stressé
alors juste pour l'expérience j'ai voulu
tenter quelque chose
l'averse du bistrot ouais j'ai pas
ralenti j'ai accéléré les images pour
essayer de booster doc gynéco assez d'un
bon du coup je vous préviens c'est
bizarre tout le monde parle très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si passionné il faudrait qu'il y ait
plus de musique urbaine a fait plus de
dix ans et vous dire ça manque de punch
complément de réalités réalités
artistiques des allemands visuellement
c'est un peu trop de soucis le terme
variété d'accord on a juste accéléré les
images le seul qui parle normalement
c'est lui dans les invités prestigieux
on a reçu également la semaine dernière
mélanie bernier et kev adams alors kiev
il connaît bien la maison mais mélanie
c'est cette première fois et a priori
elle avait jamais regardé l'émission
donc elle a tout découvert avec beaucoup
de surprise et d'amusement alors nous
aurons peut-être de recul
c'est bien d'avoir un regard neuf sur
votre programme de temps en temps
[Musique]
mais
tout cas
[Musique]
le second tour
[Applaudissements]
que ça vous plaira
à noter que j'étais pas là gens là je me
pose des questions non non à lomé lundi
à la valette à malte annonçant par
contre c'est bien de voir regarder en l1
ouais allez on passe au top gênant cette
compilation des petits moments étranges
de tp mpls que tu as un dernier truc à
nous dire que je me demande si c'est pas
mais pour que tu m'en sors pas
le fait de la peine c'est comme vous
voulez je vous dise ne prend jamais si
des d'avion comme ça et voilà oui moi je
pétais servions privé ça m'angoisse mam
est qu un jour il ya un mec plaisir je
voudrais si un match de foot dans un
avion privé et chez ben moi pareil il
brassera enfin moi j'aime bien les
avions il ya plein de monde
et ben moi pareil voilà moi j'adore moi
j'achète mes petites cacahuètes et où je
suis content quoi nous est arrivé très
vert de 30 dormir
[Musique]
il faut que tu remets on va demander aux
téléspectateurs ce qu'il en pense certes
auteur sur bobo quick je me suis à la
fin à la fal déguise bras mais tellement
d'importance
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
titillé
[Musique]
et moi je vous suivez dans les émissions
moi je vous adorez d'un grand concours
on l'a fait plusieurs fois ensemble si
vous avez gagné pas moi et c'était moi
je vous ai toujours vraiment admiré en
tant qu'animateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kassal on va très bien oui je il paraît
vraiment c'est un restaurant un grand
moment ça c'est un bon soin que des bons
souvenirs ouais bah oui faut même si au
respect des années on va sur lui aussi
une des chanteuses préférées de cyril
tina arena
tina alors le problème c'est que pendant
que tina se produisent et sur cette
scène là tout à l'heure où étaient amir
l'équipe attendait dans le hall pour le
before he série ne savais pas que tina
avait commencé son live un nom barbare
la force et vie
[Musique]
où est la vie chante comme ça
c'est que j'aime bien par contre c'était
déprimé dans tous les cantons qu hélas
[Musique]
et quelle voix tu as quoi sans enlever
c'est magnifique
elle va revenir l'adorent nommé sur
cette chanteuse l'avait mois d'août mais
quand je suis arrivé je n'entendais pas
bien de moi
voilà je suis pas quelqu'un qui chante
et c'est ce que je souhaitais
chroniqueuse qui viennent chanter comme
ça
jacky d'eau et j'adore sa chanson nation
c'est changer les paroles je voudrais
alors j'espère qu'il va revenir parce
que je suis fan nan ça va passer des
choses c'est vrai exactement plus c'est
pas un autre titre dell qu'est-ce qu'il
ya un autre titre les plots aller plus
haut pas de doute ça change mais jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
ce que j'ai préféré c'est la tête d'amir
pendant beau chantier qu'est ce qui se
passe
cougar à des clients plus jeunes j'adore
cyril fade non mais sérieux et tina je
prends parce que d'accord si je m'en
coûte aide à personne mais vraiment
j'aime beaucoup tina arena j'étais très
content de l'avoir relation à tarbes a
quand même à qui je peux rendre service
non bonjour la semaine dernière y avait
aussi le prime dès 8 ans ah oui un bon
moment qui nous a permis de faire
griller des magnifiques cadeaux à nos
plus fidèles téléspectateurs et
notamment un garçon qui fêtait son
anniversaire
ah oui et on va lui offrir un séjour au
ski parce que c'est son rêve d'aller au
ski je t'offre un séjour pour 4
personnes dans un appart ou nous v'la
porto en france au ski
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
orlando bat à
la planète encore iad apple
le jet ski comment t'es tu senti très
bien sur les cailloux avant tout cas
c'était un très beau prime time ça a
cartonné d'ailleurs merci à vous merci
travaux prennent très émouvant puisque
nous avons ainsi pu revoir les premiers
pas de certains chroniqueurs dans
l'émission et notamment ceux de jean
michel arrêt complètement oublié le
sûrement qui était le sien à l'époque on
se demande pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'intello de la banque tpm p c'est
quoi ces races ra ra sera brassera ou
jean michel maire mon cas c'est
l'intello de la bande et il a bien
défendu et l'intérêt du figaro ah oui là
bien des maux du oui regardez un peu
plus doux mais quand même arrivé et on
commence quand maxime gainey qui une
nouvelle fois sous nos regards
admiratifs de donner à tous une leçon
magistrale de télévision maintient
quand tu sais très bien comment ça
fonctionne avec les enquêtes d'action
date jour a marqué inédit lorsqu'il
s'agit images exclusives et lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une chaîne top-team il
simplement des productions et d'une
manière ou d'une autre tué l'ex nantais
souffle sur l'actualité alors qu'on
retourne les blattes aux 10 soit inédit
là ça ne pose vraiment aucun problème
reviendra sur une enquête exclusive sur
les riches mais gens qui aiment l'argent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tranquillement chez moi et ma femme
laquelle j'ai quand même suivi votre vos
conseils et puis je pars s'est arrêté
deux mois après et bmp toujours la
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle film et pas de trop près ça me
met pas en valeur
ça
le gérant la main
c'est dommage qu'ils fallaient quoi
rigoler maxime je reste dehors pour la
sto ça n'est pas d'année mais c'est en
tant que c'est pas satisfaisant
merci
[Applaudissements]